[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the Tosh home to statesman
and celebrities for over a century
Wow remember always here at the Taj yes
is gone
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
chaos has erupted in Mumbai with
multiple bombings and armed gunmen
reticule through the city
look I don't think you understand this
being an attack and we're not safe
switch off the lights
terrorists have laid siege to the
landmark Dodge
when as many as a thousand guests and
over 500 staff trapped inside you should
try to gather whoever we can any of you
have families at home there is no shame
in living I have been here 35 years this
is my home
is on a hominid the rock where they are
local police are simply not trained to
deal with attacked of this magnitude
[Music]
don't go with the doughnuts them
and I hope to stay alive in see them go
down the back stairs and straight out
the services with the Harris we all die
we take our chances
[Music]
Murdock get through this we must stick
together
[Music]
you